when you were sort of talking about
coming out to promote this movie and
then the world kind of went - you know
what in the handbag a little bit there
what was a conversation like I supposed
to among all of you was shocked you know
I think like everybody united states we
were really really shocked because when
we were making the movie and there were
the scenes where they're building that
fence it really was a reaction to the
wall that Trump was threatening to build
so it was about immigration but I don't
think any of us ever had an expectation
there would be the kind of protests and
riots that we have in Charlottesville it
was shocking and sad I also think though
that it's always just an undercurrent
that we've never completely exercised or
zone you know I'm 56 years old but but
Inc when I was growing up you know we've
gone through I grew up in Kentucky we
just gotten rid of segregation and we
felt like everything was going good we
felt like we were gonna exercise this
whole problem we really did we were
optimistic about it and unfortunately we
haven't really moved much further past
it and that's always surprising we're
surprising during the LA riots where you
just go holy crap here we are again so
you know it's something we still have to
constantly address now as parents - I
mean with everything going on in the
states and really all over the world um
does it stress you out I know it
stresses me out I have two young kids
raising kids in this climate everyone
says it's gonna be better is the next
generation gonna be better and I'm and I
always say well they're not gonna be
better we're not any better because
we're the ones that teach them so we
can't and you know abdicate our
responsibility and say like well because
they're so young and they have fresh
eyes it's like Willie they do have fresh
eyes but if they're not if they don't
see their parents actively trying to
change the world that they live in it's
not it's not going to happen for them so
it's our responsibility
this is a line and South Pacific goes on
you've got to be carefully taught yeah
yeah does it make you nervous at all a
lot of these bring me nervous that would
suck it changes see it changes
everything they listen you know all my
friends are laughing I knew it I'm tell
you feel it you go oh right well I
they're the concerns are you know what
you want from your children is you want
to make sure that they are compassionate
and that they pay attention to the rest
of the world and not just because
they're gonna be born into a life in
some ways it's gonna be very hectic and
they're gonna be chased and they're
gonna have all those things that we've
experienced and it's hard to do but
they're also going to be born into a
place of something of privilege and so
they're going to have to learn that
that's just by birth no just just by
accident and then everything else is you
have to pay attention be strong you know
you didn't put yourself in this movie
and you weren't sure you're going to be
a leading man material yeah now I feel
Giuliana and I are really good judges of
what ladies like to see sure and I just
want to say that I think you're really
wrong I don't mean to be disrespectful
just feel like I drank a little this
morning
whatever so but if women said it's not
about women really it should be George I
don't mean to give us what we were well
I'm just happy I didn't wear orange are
you saying you don't like I'm saying I
do like it but how bad were do we look
at both of us were on or it would have
looked really good okay I just feel as
if as you get older you the characters
that you want to play and the things
that your interest in playing are a
little more complex and you're hoping to
find those I've been lucky enough to
have some really interesting characters
that I've gotten to play if I find a
good director a good script I'd do it I
take rom-com for me no no no
no more of those come on I love them
I'll do one with you
I might all come on seven I'll wear
orange it'll go really well like done
one in my life